[Music]
thank you for coming how was the morning
session how was the morning session okay
fantastic it really is great to sort of
see you all here it's bright up here but
this is exactly the right time for us to
connect and collaborate here at Google
next to really understand and shape our
futures in real time I'd say in the 25
years that I've been at Deloitte gotten
to do many many exciting things and many
exciting places with great clients but
the last 19 months working with alphabet
Google and the Google cloud team has
been one of the most intellectually
enriching times of my career but also I
found myself targeting market impact at
a scale that you know added a comic on
honestly it was it's it's a watermark
high for me it's been a great and
successful partnership with Google over
the last 19 months and we are very happy
that we received Google's Google clouds
Global Services Partner of the Year this
this award is really a recognition of
real laser focus as many of you know a
great team a ton of hard work and really
unwavering commitment to collaborating
and leveraging our collective strengths
of both Google cloud and what Deloitte
can bring to our clients to really
reimagine many of you reimagine your
businesses and execute with technology
enabled innovations we have multiple
client centric solutions presses hit it
recently CRN news last week we issued a
press release as well these are
important because it talks to the kinds
of impacts and value we can bring to
your clients to you as clients every day
Google cloud sa P and Deloitte have rich
histories with one another and we've
come together and really are committed
to working with you to take advantage of
the business opportunities that you see
that we see and and take advantage and
overcome the challenges that many of our
business leaders face to get us in sort
of the right mindset for the panel in
the discussion I wanted to share a
powerful message on how fast the world
is changing we've seen this many many
times but it's really impacting
virtually every aspect of our
and with two amazing young children nine
and eleven at home and for those of you
who are parents in the audience
I'm guarantee this this video will make
you pause for a minute and think about
the world we are creating for them to
thrive in so without further ado let's
go to the video this is Alex she's five
years old and she was born into a
digital world at the edge of a
technological singularity where she
could live to be 150 years old
imagine all the advances of the last 150
years each discovery building on the
last to alter the way we live relate
consume and perceive for Alex that same
amount of industrial and societal change
will happen in her next 15 he'll
purchase digital rights from brands to
create her own clothing furniture and
decor with digital fabrics jillee
organically balanced food was grown
using nanotech she'll know someone whose
life was saved by a 3d printed organ
implanted by a doctor operating remotely
she'll carry safer digitally integrated
ID in forms of payment driven by the
blockchain of everything and that's just
until she's 20 she still has 130 years
to go
as she enters the workforce she'll take
advantage of autonomous vehicles and
ride share programs which will alter our
entire transportation infrastructure
she'll have robotic and AI driven
support tools and even colleagues the
very notion of an employee will change
all these advancements will open us up
to a new world of imagined possibilities
what role will your enterprise play in
creating this world her world you'll
need to embrace it as a freely moving
digital enterprise shedding your
technical debt if your company is
designed for this decade it won't
outlast it the pace of change will
continue to accelerate enterprises will
have to adapt faster all to serve the
once and needs of a five-year-old her
future and your future are linked and
leading that future will be your digital
enterprise it's time to reimagine your
business model your organization your
world it's time to reimagine everything
I'd like to now invite on stage three
business leaders change agents and real
true collaborators and personal friends
of mine Kevin ish brawny yon walls in
Pavan Shrivastava
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so thank you guys for joining us today
can you please maybe start with just a
little bit of background so your current
role and I know all of you are very deep
and steeped in s AP so share a little
bit about that with us all right
Pavan Chavez though I'm part of our
technology practice and I've been doing
work around this ap for last 20 years
definitely focused more around using the
innovative technologies around this ap
and cloud NS ap Hana to transform the
business and definitely we are going
through an exciting time right now
fantastic yes yarn walls for the Lord I
lead our global s ap practice I've been
working on s ap programs since I was
fifteen I think so
a long long time for the firm I also let
our us practice during the days of
up-and-coming s for Hana had to
transform our own practice frankly to be
able to better serve our customers as
well that I did to be perfect and I'm
Kevin ish Bharani I manage global
alliances for Google cloud and I also
have a long history of working with s AP
and s AP customers for the last 15 plus
years fantastic
so maybe we'll start with you Kevin very
keen to hear about what you're seeing
relevant trends and sort of the latest
headlines between s AP and Google and
your relationship so we've made
tremendous progress over the last year
since this partnership was announced in
fact many of you have seen the video and
yesterday and Diane Greene's keynote
from Bern liquor at the head of
engineering at sa P and which she really
underscores that the relationship is the
core foundation is a deep relationship
between the engineering teams that are
sitting side by side helping to Co
innovate and optimize our solutions to
better support sa P products and so I'll
give you some examples over the course
of the last year our customers were
asking for all of the SE p solutions to
be certified for google cloud and we've
done virtually all of the SVP solutions
are certified now in fact many of them
were asking for very large landscapes
for the large Hana instances and we
announced it sa piece a fire in June for
terabyte availability we now announced
at Google Nexus week availability of 7
tera bytes and natively up to
18 terabytes by the end of next year so
we can handle the largest customers in
the world we are also for customers that
mean something very short-term have a
bare-metal option up to 20 terabytes so
very significant improvement on the
instant sizes in terms of availability
but we're also Co innovating with s ap
we've done things like integrated
bigquery as a Google bigquery
with s AP HANA so we can enable petabyte
scale for asipi HANA in enable use cases
where large retailers are looking at
tremendous amount of data and want to do
dynamic upselling and cross-selling or
genomic profiling we're working with s
AP in areas around Android so within the
core SP platform the asipi cloud
platform you can develop native
experiences in Android and we're working
in areas around areas like machine
learning embedding that into the core
business process of SP applications
thank heaven just watching the speed at
which Google has moved into the S AP
space it's been nothing short of
impressive because if you go twenty-four
months ago all that you describe it's
happened in that time arise and it's
pretty amazing just to see the
engineering talent you know Pavan I know
you've been working closely with Google
for quite a while at this point too
right close to two years
let me ask you what does it mean for
Deloitte in your mind to be not only a
premier partner but also to have been
acknowledged by Kevin and the team
around the global services partner of
the year yeah and I think first of all
it's a great honor to be the premium
partner and also excited to get the news
around us being the global partner of
the year which is amazing and I think it
has come at the right time what that
really means to us is we are committed
to do lot more investment into this area
and build our capabilities around Google
cloud platform and the reality is our
clients are going through this digital
transformation with sa piece new product
line as for Hana and for over the next
seven years we would see a lot of
momentum in the market around that area
which means they are expecting us to
help them adapt to these technologies
and the cloud platform together
obviously understanding the business
benefit of how they can leverage cloud
platform capabilities for business how
to transform adapted
which also means we are heavily
investing in this area and Google cloud
platform is one of the important aspect
of our go-to-market strategy so this
partnership really means that we have
the highest level of access within
Google about the tools technologies
innovation support and leadership
commitment to go into the market and
that is what we are going to bring to
our clients to transform their business
not only that with that backdrop we are
we have also announced our collaboration
and alliance with Google to bring our
industry expertise our vast experience
around the CP implementation our talent
pool as well as Google cloud innovative
technology to help client extend the
digital core platform capability by
leveraging Google machine learning and
analytics capabilities so really excited
about this partnership fantastic and I
know you know Yann you sort of predicted
the tsunami that we're seeing I was sort
of in the room I know Kevin was at sa P
at the time this was quite a while ago I
might ask you for stock pics later but
really what does sa PS you know sort of
partnership a market relationship with
Google what does that mean - you know
our collective s ap clients into some of
the prospective clients in the audience
yeah so I say P of course has a lot of
tools and accelerators available that we
utilize as well to better serve our
customers and to to build basically on
top of that they add Google to the mix
frankly that's gonna add a lot of power
as well and additional tools and
accelerators that will come available
over the next months and years basically
then someone that is still still taking
shape and it frankly it enables us to do
things for our customers that simply
weren't possible before fantastic and I
think Kevin you know fair to ask you a
similar line of thinking you know what
does the Deloitte market relationship
with Google what does that mean for our
collective s ap clients from your
perspective I think there's tremendous
value for clients and that Deloitte has
a long history of working with s AP
clients and
understanding how to manage the
landscapes in fact Deloitte's one of the
largest systems integrators around SCP
in the world and that's what we
particularly found attractive but then
when you think of the journey to the
cloud there's multiple steps the first
is the migration and the ability to
de-risk it for clients with prepackaged
migration services from Deloitte
combined with the next leg of the
journey when customers are looking at
transformation how do I you know change
my business processes leveraging machine
learning and analytics that generally
involves a deep requirement around
industry business process and so
Deloitte's industry DNA is also
something that's you know an important
part of the solution then lastly a
number of customers just want a managed
service they want to move their
solutions or ERP solutions as for Hana
example into the cloud and they want to
essentially outsource it and so this new
offering that we work together with the
Deloitte teams so that there's a turnkey
managed service that includes both then
management of the landscape as well as
bundling in the Google cloud services
all in one turnkey construct for the
customer is something we're seeing
customers quite interested in fantastic
I know beyond you you talked a little
bit about the offerings that will be
created and I know you certainly Pavan
have worked sort of tirelessly on this
as a be offering construct around
digital transformation can you share a
little bit what this digital
transformation mean with sa peon GCP
yeah so so essentially and I think Kevin
also touched upon the same topic our
clients are into various stages of the
journey and they are looking our help
and Google's help to help them make the
business case because a lot of them are
still struggling to make a business case
to move into the cloud get the full
benefit of cloud so essentially what we
did it we already have a very robust sa
P implementation services available and
operate services available we laid over
our Google and Deloitte cloud
capabilities on top of it to create a
storefront where we can help client from
end to end building a strategy building
a business case understanding the
benefit of cloud from the business
standpoint not so much from technology
only so initial taking them to the
journey to build a business case
strategy and then moving more into the
implementation and migration some of our
clients are doing a left and shift
migration as their first step before
they fully realize the value of Si P by
moving to s4 Hana and some of them are
starting what we call it a clean ERP
Greenslade leaving the legacy behind so
we have laid build artifacts solutions
around it in fact we had made some
strategic position to help client doing
lift and shift to Google cloud platform
we are also building adapters and
integration with the Google cloud
platform with our tool sets which makes
it very compelling easy and seamless and
last but not the least I think focusing
more on managed services and operate
business we are seeing a great momentum
right now where clients are adapting
Google cloud platform and they need NSI
who can bring an end to end service to
manage and operate them seamlessly
provide the transparency and the tool
sets to manage the Google cloud platform
so definitely all of those services
under one umbrella that's what we are
bringing to our clients so I think I
think a number of the things the points
you made is talking to the landscape
that we see the market landscape and the
needs that our clients are articulating
where are we you know this is to the
group where are we in the game in terms
of how big is that pipeline how fast is
it going to convert give us a sense of
the velocity that that will likely to
see over the next 12 to 24 months
obviously early innings but but it could
it the tipping point could be quite
quick I was gonna I was gonna say some
of my thunder until the last couple of
minutes frankly right and so as you know
in Deloitte and in front of sa P as well
before s4 was even called s4 I predicted
that there was going to be a tsunami of
opportunity basically around s4 even put
an exact date to it and I was proven
right but the interesting thing is what
most of the people in the law don't
remember I actually made a second
prediction then where the timing it was
a bit harder to predict but it was going
to be called tsunami 2.0 even a bigger
wave and that's the whole combination of
move to cloud infrastructure but also
SAS solutions even for sa ps4 as well
single tenant multi-tenant there's going
to be enormous wave that frankly the
biggest issue that all customers and and
consulting firms will have an SI p is
frankly run Talent because it's going to
be such a massive wave of opportunity
hitting us over the next 12 - you know
years frankly to come that it's going to
be very difficult to get to manage the
workload and just order a magnitude in
terms of size of the prize number of
clients can any of you share some of
your thoughts on Tam I think you could
easily say that over even 7 to 10 years
you're talking hundreds of billions of
dollars worth of business
I mean it's humongous yeah I think when
you look at s VPS install base of just
European it's roughly 60,000 customers
plus and they're adding new ones every
day and as those customers move from
their traditional ERP environments to s4
Hana those are the times there's
tremendous business benefit there and as
they do that migration that is the
opportune time to move to the cloud
because you oftentimes need to do a
hardware refresh you may not have the
skills in-house so getting a managed
service where you get the services and
the cloud ultra a turnkey migration
we're seeing those things could just go
hand-in-hand fantastic I mean it's it's
incredible when you think about the size
of the way that you you know you did
predict it and we're about to surf it
with our clients and collectively as a
collaboration with us ap seems like
there are a lot of offerings that are
being built you know around these hosted
ASAP on GCP solutions and I was
wondering you know Pavan given the role
that you play in terms of market facing
how how is Deloitte with Google Google's
teams how are we helping customers move
to GCP so that they can take advantage
of not only the services that that are
there today but what what Kevin and the
team are shaping for tomorrow yeah so
there are multiple stages of clients and
their transformation journey and our
offering associated with it so there's a
set of client who are doing a lift and
shift essentially just taking their
existing workload and moving it to the
cloud to take the benefit of cloud
platform and then there are other set of
clients who are just migrated
from their traditional databases to
leverage the in-memory Hana platform
Hana databases from sa P we consider
mostly this is lift and shift or
technology upgrade so we have acquired a
new solution in the market called Etta
data which helps us take these solutions
and do a mass scale migration in fact we
have built a factory mass migration
Factory internally that does this very
quickly using all the automation and
script around it the second part of
conversation that we are having with our
client is which is I think predominantly
happening right now is s for Hana a
Greenfield implementation because a lot
of our clients are thinking that's the
best way to start leaving all the legacy
behind so we have built our architecture
artifacts solutions a to help them set
up install run sa p on GC p but also
take the conversation away from just the
is base to platform as a service and how
we can leverage other feature function
of Google platforms such as api's as
well as machine learning and bigquery
and analytics which is a game changer
here so those are the major areas and
major set of options that we are
bringing to the client how we are
helping our client obviously it's a
combination of having a right s ap skill
as well as having a right GCP and
platform skills cloud native app
development skills and infrastructure
scale and architecture skilled we are
training and certifying hundreds and
thousands of people in our US as well as
in our India practice to get ready to
help this tsunami that yan is talking
about so definitely that's that's where
we are working most imperfect you you
you touched on lift and shift and
migration and the importance of enabling
tools to get there and you mention data
data I'm not sure the audience really
knows what what that stands for or what
it means and I also think it's it's very
complimentary to fellow strata
acquisition by Google so it's worth it
probably a couple of sound bytes on that
from from some of you on the panel yes I
can talk a little bit about data data
essentially it is anywhere to any
so you move from any combination of your
source platform to an any combination on
any of the cloud platform you can go
with it is basically take the
application as a container and move
exactly as it is and if you want to
transform while you are doing there are
a certain level of transformation is
also possible for example you are
changing your operating systems those
things can be handled as part of the
adder data tool and given if you want to
talk a little bit about the velocerator
sure you know in Vella strata
complements that by enabling you to
essentially shadow your environment on
Prem and into the cloud or if you're
running on another cloud and you need to
change the hypervisor to run natively on
GCP so really the to work together to
really make the migration more seamless
for customers perfect I want to dig a
little bit deeper in some of the
previous points again bringing the s AP
context to life so how is Google really
helping s AP and and their clients you
talked about the instant the massive
install base really embraced not only
the technologies that we see today that
are available today that they still need
to move to that but but also that are
gonna define the next wave of technology
advancements that you talked about the
portfolio play of alphabet Google and
bringing that to bear but the other way
the other way of of technology
advancements that are right in front of
us yeah what we see is that that it's
happening this wave is happening in kind
of multi horizon journey so customers
are saying I want to move my existing
ear P landscape as an example or other s
ap products into the cloud as phase one
I want to get the TCO reduction and I
want to get the agility but then in
Phase two I want to once I actually have
all the data in one place how do I now
leverage that data for better insights
and actually transformed my business
process and created new business models
and so in phase one what we're seeing is
that as customers move one of the
biggest things the benefits they see and
moving to get to Google cloud is not
only our price performance and there's
there's ample analyst data that we have
the best price performance but it's
about reliability security and network
so from a reliability perspective you
know again lots of analyst data that we
have the best uptime which is so
critical when you're running
mission-critical solutions like ASAP
because when s ap shuts down the
business shuts down
and from a security perspective you know
our cut you know it's some of the most
sensitive data whether that's financial
data customer data etc and so this
ability for our cloud be the security
that we deliver you know there's a lot
of uniqueness to that in that we build
every part of the hardware stack and we
have a root of trust chip built in so
that we can ensure the security in fact
many of you are familiar with recent
security vulnerabilities that the chip
set with like scepter and meltdown
Google actually identified those
vulnerabilities patched it and announced
it to the world so security is you know
one of key differentiators and then from
a network perspective not only in the
network performance believe the largest
network in the world and we have
actually enough network enough fiber
under the ocean and so for it to support
a 400% growth in the network required it
so if the internet grew for her percent
we have enough network and that we're
not stopping there and so this is
tremendous scale this is the same scale
of all the Google products you know and
love today brought to enterprise mission
critical systems we spent over 30
billion on investment in order to
deliver the market leading platform and
then as customers move to the the second
wave of their journey leveraging you
know market leading capabilities like
tensor flow machine learning and
bigquery analytics enables customers to
not only just harvest insights but
actually start to come up with
completely new business models yeah I
was in the leadership circle yesterday I
was great to see pH kind of articulate
the journey that our customers have to
go on very much in line with what you
described so for those of you maybe I've
missed that we can we can connect you to
that to that methodology and approach
it's simple yet hard to do I do want to
come to and by the way I'm still
lobbying to see Google's Navy which
includes ships and submarines and issue
didn't know it's public but we're trying
to get that invite maybe to lucky winner
in the audience we can make that happen
what is by the way might my son really
wants it wants to view at age 11 he
thinks Google is very cool Deloitte open
cloud also very very cool and another
enabling technology that we have can you
share a little bit about what is
Deloitte open cloud how does it work
why is it easy to consume
for enterprise clients yeah by the pavan
er yeah so so essentially the Lord open
cloud is a framework that we have
developed with a future in the mind as
we are moving into cloud space lot of
our clients would whether we like it or
not would be into a multi cloud
environment and and we would see some
application running at one cloud another
would be running another cloud so our
open cloud really provides a framework
to manage and give a single pane of
glass for all the applications running
at different clouds so there is a cloud
to cloud integration there are all the
essential services aspect of managing a
platform of any of the public cloud
provider anything that is essential from
DevOps automation infrastructure
management logging monitoring security
reporting and billing solutions around
it as well as as we move to the second
layer of pass layer we will have to
manage the custom-built
app as well so Deloitte open cloud is
our branded offering in the market to
manage any of the application from top
to bottom end to end as a managed
services platform and maybe speak to the
contractual element why is it easy why
isn't it easy contracting mechanism for
clients so what we are doing is instead
of client going to an SI or a provider
for services going to a cloud provider
for subscription our open cloud allows
you to have a single place or single
shop go through Deloitte we have done
all the contracting behind the scene
with major cloud providers such as
Google cloud and essentially we are the
front to the client a single SLA based
offering to the clients essentially we
take the ownership of you know providing
the SLA based on Google cloud platform
managing end-to-end not only that even
if you tomorrow you want to extend and
enhance you are just dealing with us
from all the way to application tier to
the infrastructure management as well as
the infrastructure itself right so this
essentially simplifies the the
transformation journey that we are
talking about
and not only that Kevin touched upon
having more of a bare-metal options so
we are also extending this through other
networking solutions to extend our open
cloud to a bare-metal option and making
it easy to consume is critical and being
able to meet the client wherever their
needs are is is critical so up to loud
does that yawn and I think Kevin is well
the you know we're here in sunny
beautiful California but the the global
frame is really important in our global
leader for for us ap what are some of
the nuances around the world that you're
seeing around the demand for this
service as a pion GCP and also you know
predictions to that extent to you know
where are you seeing innovation out
there that that we can bring here or
here to they're just curious what you
both see yeah so two fold I guess right
one is um you know in the in the old
days I mean all that's in up until at
two three years ago maybe something new
would come along and we would do a
massive project or something right and
then you know eventually 18 months down
the road or something you would deliver
this right if you see now actually it's
sort of like the opposite yeah
eventually you'll deliver something big
at the end maybe two but along the way
now there's a lot of things she already
can do and so I already came up like
lift and shift you know you can do that
now you don't have to wait until the
journey is complete to s4 you can just
take what you have now and already go
for a lower TCO as well but that's sorta
like the cloud migration piece which in
itself will be huge of course right but
and if you look at like IOT enabled
supply chain as an enormous interest
around and of course if you look at AI
and machine learning and there as well
it's not just about waiting to design
this around s4 only there are certain
things where does a business case to do
that along the way even where does
sometimes massive opportunity for
savings with specific business processes
to utilize a standard s AP scenarios run
Leonardo as an example but in
combination with Google makes it even
more powerful and what you see is I
think over the next year and years is a
combination of sa P making investments
Google making investments firms like the
Lloyd making invest
and we're going to see enormous
possibilities along the way and and I
know you're just in Europe last week
trying to get a feel for that landscape
versus APJ versus here in the US what
what either you guys are seeing in terms
of pipeline demand conversion different
consumption types yeah it's interesting
and you know one of the reasons we're
way back when I predicted tsunami was
for multiple reasons right one is the
first time tsunami is water level
recedes you see though investment in all
the technology s APEC sees an example
drying up and then of course you know
new wave forming but also tsunami it
sort of ripples of course and somehow in
the u.s. because of maybe the economic
cycle as well but just business is maybe
a bit more willing to invest in new
things immediately Europe a bit more
cautious maybe asia-pac a little bit in
between but what you see now is that
ripple effect where I used to get phone
calls from people in Europe like hey
yeah you're talking about it tsunami
when is it hitting us and I was like
well it's coming they're like well it's
not here yet it's not here yet and then
all of a sudden you get to Pho panicking
phone calls asking for resources and
help and assistance because all of a
sudden the pipeline explodes right and
that's sort of the phase we're in right
now and the pipeline has been building
up the big projects about to start some
of them already started that's the phase
we're in if you look at a media and an
Asia pack that's coming as well perfect
and Kevin I know you and I were in
Canada several months ago and then we
were we had our teams in Europe pushing
pretty hard on GCP NSA peon GCP some of
the things that you're seeing from the
Google perspective yeah I would say that
when you think of sa p on GCP globally
we're seeing adoption happen and
throughout the globe but in there's
certain countries that were we're seeing
the adoption happen faster as yon
mentioned the u.s. clearly UK we're
starting to see a big uptick in areas
like France and in Germany and in the
Benelux region as well as I'd say
Australia and Japan those are there's
where we probably seen the largest set
of opportunities right now but like I
said this is really spreading as Yann
mentioned it is a tsunami we're seeing
it spread to a number of
other countries and and you know one of
the things that's gonna be so important
is just for customers to really
prioritize and be ahead of the curve
because I think one of the biggest
challenges I see is the services a
partner community needs to ensure that
the scale and the people are on the
ground in order to help with these so
planning ahead is really important in
this journey and I mean that brings a
great point around potential friction or
bottlenecks that we might have our
capacity constraints that we might have
whether they're human or or technology
related maybe some comments on the early
innings where you're seeing the friction
points what's slowing this tsunami from
hitting faster versus you know it taking
its you know it's due course so one of
the things you know more and more
countries around the world are expecting
their data to stay in country
the data sovereignty issues have become
pretty significant around the globe not
just in Europe but in Asia and Latin
America and so forth
and so we're putting up new availability
zones as I mentioned we've put thirty
billion dollars in infrastructure we're
putting up new availability zones new
data centers could pop up every
literally every month we've now 50
availability zones around the globe and
so for our from our side that's
extremely important to be able to serve
customers locally and ensure the data
sovereignty requirements perfect you
know Pavan I and curious there are a lot
of options for clients as to service
providers right that they could
potentially choose so what is the
delight difference here you know I've
spent time in sapphire latter stages my
career last couple two three years
because of Google and that that's one
impressive showing that we have there in
terms of the pinnacle or dewater what
makes us different why us to take you on
the cloud journey to GCP yeah so there
are various reason that you know we are
at the top and one of the leading system
integrator but I'll touch upon a couple
of points here first is if you look at
analyst report and if you look at our
awards and recognition we've been we've
been getting the Pinnacle Award for last
multiple years in fact this year we also
got the Leonardo partner of the Year
award which is exceptionally you know
well for us that proves our ability into
the space of machine learning and cloud
platform also Google's recognition for
us as a partner of the year and our
partnership around going after digital
transformation with a say P so a lot to
talk we're not talking but our analysts
are talking everybody is talking that we
do have a pole position in the market to
help our clients go through this journey
in fact we may we have the most number
of successful s for Hana implementation
on any cloud platform we have the most
number of solution that is built around
Google cloud platform so definitely
that's one area second area is our
talent pool I mean more than 18,000 sa P
practitioners and thousands of them has
been certified on ass ap as well as on
Google cloud platform in fact we have
more than 200 practitioners who are
certified together with ass AP and
Google cloud platform which is a unique
skill that we need to bring for all of
us ap clients when we are talking about
business case to implementation to
migration to operate business so and we
are certifying more into our talent pool
we are making a lot of acquisition which
is more related to this s AP and the
cloud specific area and the last point I
think which is the most important is the
innovation I think we have the most
number of industry use case and business
use case that will deliver value to our
client how best you can leverage the
capability of a cloud platforms such as
Google cloud platform or versus sa psap
cloud platform running on a Google cloud
platform
and we have created more number of
assets and that really solve the
business problem or extend the extend
the features functionality for digital
core beyond just a digital core using
those cloud platforms so those
innovations are really making us leader
in the market to help client and those
are the real reason that anybody would
choose us over other si to help them if
you have time I would definitely talk
about an innovative solution that we
have built and
we show you a short demo around it what
we call it is it's an automated invoice
management solution which is built on
using Google cloud platform capability
as well as Sapa Leonardo capability is
starting all the way from getting the
invoice and processing it and all the
way going up to the payment and that is
a solution that we are productizing and
commercializing and taking to the market
along with Google and the SEBI together
and essentially what it does is it uses
Google cloud platform storage unit is
uses Google a vision API as well as
tensorflow model using Google auto ml
machine learning at the front of it and
at the back and for gir clearing
clearing and the payment part of it it
is using a CP Leonardo component so it
sincerely really bringing the power of
our business knowledge along with the
Google cloud platform capability nsab
capability together so if you are
interested I can definitely are you
interested play a demo it's pretty sharp
are you interested
that's all I think there's general all
right that's good get this thing go
let's get going with the demo I'm gonna
come back to you get what I promised so
essentially as you can see if it's gonna
run fast you have an option of scanning
invoice viewing an invoice when invoice
is created in sa B here we are looking
at currently as you can see the bucket
there is no invoice left so we are
picking a paper copy or email or scan
copy right now so you can see this is an
invoice right
and apparently we will use Google vision
API to scan this invoice and the OCR
characters will be read through using
Google API and behind the scene the auto
ml is running which is really getting
smarter as you keep you know scanning
more and more invoices so as you can see
we are just uploading the invoice at
this point of time and it says
successfully uploaded now if you go to
look at the bucket you should be able to
see a new invoice appearing there there
you go so the actual physical
copy has been scanned stored into the
Google cloud platform and now we are
going to look at the invoice so this is
where the AAP clerk can look at the
actual physical invoice and the data
that has been read through the scanner
vision API and see if there is any
correction needed you can also see that
green bar on the top which says the
confidence factor is 92% which means the
ml is working behind the scene and
intelligently trying to read the
characters of invoice at this point of
time you can make correction if it is
needed but hoping that as machine
learning gets smarter you don't have to
make lot of Corrections here so this is
the physical copy coming from there and
this is on the left side you would see
what machine learning and vision API was
able to read through so if you go to the
bottom you can have a submit button and
as soon as you press the submit button
it's going to go to s AP and create the
invoice so let's see what it does there
so just showing you the different values
unit price quantity amount and press the
submit button it says you want to submit
it yes and it's going to create invoice
so 7 3 8 1 let's remember the invoice
number here long num number and now
we're going to go back to the tiles in
the front which is a fury app and now we
are logging into a say P and searching
if the invoice has been created so then
we're going to type the same numbers
press ko there you go G and C the
invoice is already posted and if you
click on it it is going to show you the
invoice and remember it is it has some
metadata which is a hyperlink going back
to Google Cloud storage and reading all
the data from there you see in the
bottom the attachment link is there so
we can definitely open a physical copy
from the same screen there so you can
imagine all you did is you just press 1
click call summit and that's it the
invoice is already created there and I
think there's one step we if you are
really about the old way of doing things
logging directly into the sa P GUI you
can run your mirror transaction
go for the company code and it is going
to show you if that invoice is already
created there just to make sure that yes
Fury app in the front or in the back end
you can log in and you can see both
invoices are created this used to be a
big issue you have to develop the hose
here capability go through a document
management solution but leveraging
Google capability you can do that very
easily and the subscription cost for
vision API and Google ml is very low
cost model as compared to any other
solution I think one thing that's unique
to is versus the OCR approaches of the
past is this learns over time so as
these new invoices formats come to you
every day
it's learning and it's adapting
on-the-fly yeah absolutely and that's a
beauty effect that your effort goes
keeps going down as you keep going
further down all right see that's a demo
no I love it well we'll go to the
audience here in a minute from questions
I do want to come back Kevin to the
ability to co engineer with you with
Google one of the things that was
appealing to the Deloitte team I think
was this idea of Cohen Generico create
and innovate and so can you maybe share
some of the ways that you know people
like Deloitte as well as customers can
Co innovate co-create with you we saw a
solution here that I know our team
worked with your team to get it to done
absolutely I think one classic area of
that is in the areas of machine learning
on how we can optimize business
processes and you know there's some
examples right now where we're
co-creating let's say with s AP and
joint customers for example in retail we
have customers we're working together
with a furniture company that wants to
bring and essentially do image search
against all their catalogs so I can take
a picture of a desk and it matches
against what the you know what pictures
in the data file within the SP catalog
there's a lot of work that goes into
that it takes an army of data scientists
it takes a lot of time with auto ml
together with our engineers and auto ml
we simplified that so it can literally
be done in hours what would take weeks
or months and it's at a fraction of the
and so these are the kind of things
we're doing together with with joint
customers we're working with customers
that want to take google shopping trends
information and enrich that into their
SAT assortment planning process so that
you have a richer assortment planning
process it takes into account all of the
trends that are happening in the market
we have customers that we're working
with to take our ad tech content our
rich profile and propensity to buy
information and pull that together with
SOPs omni-channel solutions so that we
can do things like you know do precision
marketing when you're doing marketing
year it's only as good as the target
market that you've identified and so
these are the kind of things we're doing
in order to really help customers get to
completely new innovative business
processes I think at least my experience
has been the ability to bring the
different pieces of Google Cloud which
is phenomenal and then Google itself
which is bigger and then alphabet more
broadly is is really second to none so
it's been it's been great to see how you
orchestrate that on your side with
important partners like us but also
critical customer so
[Music]